الرئيس يتفوق على رد فعلك قريبًا ،
وأقول إننا نتعلم كيف نتعايش معها ،
وليس لدينا خيار ، لا يمكننا حبس
أنفسنا في قبو مثل
جو ، هل لديه القدرة
على حبس نفسه ، لا أعرف أنه
من الواضح أنه جنى الكثير من المال في مكان ما ،
لكن لديه هذا الشيء حول العيش في
الطابق السفلي ، لا يستطيع الناس فعل
ذلك بالمناسبة أنا كرئيس لا أستطيع
فعل ذلك ، أحب أن أضع نفسي في
الطابق السفلي أو في غرفة جميلة  في البيت
الأبيض واذهب بعيدًا لمدة عام ونصف
حتى يختفي ، لا يمكنني فعل ذلك ، ولا أستطيع فعل ذلك
، وكيرستن في كل اجتماع كان لدي في
كل اجتماع ، وسألتقي بالعديد
من العائلات بما في ذلك عائلات النجمة الذهبية
والعائلات العسكرية
كل  مقابلتي واضطررت إلى مقابلتهم ،
كان من
المروع إلغاء كل شيء
قلته ، أنت تعلم أن هذا أمر خطير
وأنت تعرفه وأنت تعلم أنني اكتشفته
تعلمت الكثير تعلمت الكثير من
الأطباء العظماء والمستشفيات العظيمة
و  لقد تعافيت الآن 99.9
من الشباب
استعادوا 99 شخصًا  علينا أن نتعافى ،
لا يمكننا إغلاق أمتنا ، علينا أن
نفتح مدرستنا
ولا يمكننا إغلاق أمتنا أو
لن يكون لديك
أمة وبالطبع قال مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إن
الشباب يمكن أن يمرضوا  مع
covet 19 ويمكنني اجتيازه نائب الرئيس بايدن ، أريد التحدث على
نطاق واسع عن الإستراتيجية على
الرغم من أنه يمكنك الرد على 30
ثانية من فضلك مرة أخرى لدي سؤال
ليس رقم واحد يقول إننا أه أنت
تعلم أننا نتعلم العيش مع  عندما
يتعلم الناس الموت معها ،
سيكون لدى أهل المنزل كرسي فارغ على
طاولة المطبخ هذا الصباح ،
يذهب الرجل أو الزوجة إلى الفراش
الليلة ويصلان لمحاولة لمس
عاداتهم حيث ذهبت زوجته أو زوجهم
للتعلم  لنتعايش معها ، هيا
نموت معها
لأنه لم يقل أبدًا إنه
خطير ،
متى كانت آخر مرة هل هذا
خطير حقًا ما زلنا خطرين ،
أخبر الناس أنه أمر خطير الآن ماذا
يجب أن يفعلوا حيال
الخطر وتقول  أنا لا أتحمل أي مسؤولية اسمحوا
لي  تحدث عن عذرك ،
فأنا أتحمل المسؤولية الكاملة ، فليس
خطأي أنها جاءت إلى هنا ، إنها
خطأ الصين وأنت تعرف ما ليس
خطأ جو أنه جاء هنا إما
أنه خطأ الصين ، لقد منعوه من
الذهاب إلى بقية الصين من أجل  في
الغالب
لكنهم لم يمنعوه من الخروج
إلى العالم بما في ذلك أوروبا
ونائب الرئيس بايدن ، الحقيقة هي أنه
عندما علمنا
أنه قادم عندما حدث ما حدث ، قال
الرئيس
إنه قال لا تقلق إنه  سيذهب
بعيدًا بعيد الفصح ، لا تقلق من
الطقس الدافئ ، لا تقلق ، ربما يحقن
مادة التبييض ، قال إنه كان يمزح عندما
قال إن الكثير من الناس اعتقدوا أن
مجموعة كاملة من الأشياء التي
قالها الرئيس كانت خطيرة حتى اليوم
إنه يعتقد أننا في زمام الأمور ، فنحن على
وشك خسارة 200000 شخص آخر ،
يبدو الرئيس ترامب ، ربما فقط
لإنهاء هذا ،
كنت أمزح في ذلك ، لكن فقط لإنهاء
هذا
عندما أغلقت ، قال إنه لا ينبغي أن
أغلق
، واستمر ذلك  أشهر ماذا
قالت نانسي بيلوسي نفس الشيء الذي كانت
ترقص فيه في شوارع الحي الصيني في
سان فرانسيسكو ،
لكن عندما أغلقت قال إن هذا
شيء فظيع ، فأنت مصاب برهاب الأجانب ، أعتقد أنه
وصفني بالعنصرية
ولأنني كنت أغلقها في الصين الآن
يقول إنه يجب علي  لقد أغلقته في وقت
سابق ، فقط جو ، لم أقل
أيًا من تلك الأشياء
التي تحدثت عنها بالتأكيد عن
رهاب الأجانب في سياق مختلف ،
لم يكن الأمر يتعلق
بإغلاق الحدود أمام الصينيين القادمين إلى
الولايات المتحدة